et puis sur le terrain au 75e jour de
cette guerre en ukraine continuent à
pilonner le donbass non loin de cramât
torse qu'on va retrouver tout de suite
tarek qu'à une notre envoyé spécial
tarek bonjour 9 mai date symbolique mais
pas de victoire a annoncé tout à l'heure
par vladimir poutine car sur le terrain
l'armée russe elle a beaucoup de mal à
avancer
tout à fait ce 9 mai un goût amer disons
pour la mère russe en particulier dans
cette région du dombass où nous nous
trouvons puisqu'il est difficile de
parler de triomphe major ou deux
victoires écrasantes l'armée russe a
toujours du mal avancé là mais il n'a
toujours pas réussi à contrôler une
grande ville du donbass de même il est
difficile pour la mairesse de d'établir
ce couloir qui part des régions
séparatistes contrôlé par les pro russe
en 2014 jusqu'à la crimée et jusqu'au
sud de ce but n'est toujours pas
réalisée même si le dombass de manière
générale et considérez donc comme une
cible de majeur l'armée russe donc
avance lentement elles mêmes contraintes
des fois accusé comme c'est le cas en ce
moment à au niveau de la région
d'euractiv et du nord-ouest disions
alors ce 9 mai ici dont basse tout le
monde s'en moque qu'ils s'agissent
d'officiels des mers auxquelles nous
avons parlé des simples citoyens ou même
des soldes à titre d'exemple nous avons
pu nous entretenir hier avec un soldat
russe qui a rejoint l'armée ukrainienne
et qui souhaite plus que tout la défaite
de la russie c'est un peu le sentiment
général ici dans nos bases ou de la
détermination reste très présente et la
résistance face à la russie très forte
les armes occidentales continuent à
arriver dans cette région et elle
commence à faire la différence mais elle
n'arrive pas toutefois à empêcher toutes
ces frappes qui continue ici dans cette
région comme c'était le cas avant-hier à
bir le rif cas avec cette école qui a
été frappé ces dizaines de civils qui
ont été tués ou comme c'était le cas ce
matin même akram à tort sq merci
beaucoup tarek caille notre envoyée